on n'a pas tous grandi par et s'assure
que parmi vous ou vos proches il ya
peut-être des gens qui ont grandi
empoigné comme moi le monde du foyer
pour ceux qui connaissent pas c'est
c'est un espèce d'internât tu voyais des
internats aujourd'hui comme on l'a vu à
la télé ou dans des films mais plus avec
une ambiance moins stricte plus familial
avec des éducateurs qui sont plus
compréhensifs c'est un espèce de cadres
c'est pour créer des cadres le foyer moi
j'ai eu des éducateurs qui rentraient
chez eux le soir et donc j'en ai parlé
avec lui aujourd'hui il rôles et leurs
enfants leur disait et tu peux arrêter
de t'occuper d'autres enfants et occuper
un peu de nous puisqu'il s'occupait pas
il faisait des nuits il dormait avec
nous dans la science des animateurs et
rentrez pas chez eux
oui il ya une minorité de connard comme
de partout mais parler s'il vous plaît
des éducateurs bons qui donnent toute
leur vie c'est un métier hyper altruiste
c'est bien de parler des éducateurs qui
font de la merde et il faut les faux les
blâmer il faut les virer les fonds à
parler mais c'est sûr que c'est pas la
majorité
si sûr et certain ses trois métiers
d'altruisme pour qu'ils choisissent de
le faire pour être un [ __ ]
tu vois c'est pas possible donc du coup
je me suis dit moi parlons de positivité
et soyons positifs comme dans tout ce
que je fais et j'ai fait cette bd pour
rendre aussi hommage à ses éducateurs
qui aujourd'hui encore par vocation font
ce métier tu peux pas faire ce métier
parce que tu as envie de gagner des
thunes c'est pas vrai que j'aime pas ta
vie avec ça tu n'aimes pas bien tu as
vite moi ils sont venus me voir en me
disant ça te dirait d'être placés quand
tu es gamin et qu'on dit ça te dirait de
les renvoyer dans une chambre tout seul
avec plein d'enfants et tous et la colo
étudie oui mais qui prend pas en compte
que tu vas pas avoir des parents et du
coup j'ai dit oui et j'ai été placés
parce que j'ai dit oui il y avait une
demande mais c'est une demande un peu
bâtarde parce que tu sais pas vraiment
de ce que tu acceptes tu vois mes et ça
allait aussi à ma famille ils sont dix
bas nous on galère vraiment on a deux
autres enfants qui viennent d'arriver
donc forcément ça va nous soulager
puisque moi j'avais déjà 7 ans et les
deux les deux les deux étaient des
nouveaux nés tout a été fait
naturellement et accepter même par mois
et quand je suis revenu de vacances de
ma famille d'accueil puisqu'il avait
déjà une famille d'accueil
j'avais déjà dans une famille d'accueil
depuis mai 5 6 ans les vacances y aller
en vacances là-bas et j'adorerais ça
c'était trop bien est ce que c'était que
les vacances donc du coup j'étais
content et là quand il faut y est venu
le chercher après les vacances de ma
famille d'accueil je me suis dit merde
merde là il ya un problème je vais plus
voir ma famille en fait et j'ai commencé
à pleurer tous les soirs mais là où
c'est quand même dans mon malheur simple
ça va c'est que moi j'étais que pauvre
il ya des enfants qui étaient placés
parce que les parents l'étape et il y en
a qui se faisait violer et un acquis qui
avaient des histoires horribles atroce
il y avait des meurtres et tous les
gamins aient vu leurs parents mourir
devant eux et tout ça on ne savait pas
gelé su que maintenant quand j'ai parlé
avec mes éducateurs et donc moi j'étais
que pour au final les souvenirs les plus
douloureux du foyer ça reste
tous les moments de solitude où je
rentrais pas chez moi c'était ça le plus
le plus dur le plus le plus marquant et
les moments de bonheur ça c'est tous les
moments de bonheur c'est tout ce que
j'ai fait ce que j'ai que j'aurais pas
pu faire chez noir les activités je fais
du cheval j'ai mon galop 4
j'ai fait du ski je suis allé à la mère
avait fait tous ces trucs là j'ai
découvert avec le foyer en restant chez
moi et j'admets de la vigile aurait
découvert mais vraiment jamais comment
tu leur as compterait aujourd'hui tu
vérifies qu'est ce que tu ressentais ce
manque pour ta famille tu te retrouve
quand même dans un endroit où tu es seul
complètement dans une pièce qui est plus
grande que là où tu habites avec cinq
personnes quand je te disais cette femme
de chaleur que j'avais dans mes
souvenirs quand tu arrives au foyer que
les soldes en tâchant aller plus de
chaleur dans sa chambre il fait froid il
fait vide
j'étais sont pas seuls dans le foyer
mais seul dans ma chambre les seuls dans
ta chambre c'est des angoisses et des du
silence le silence moi j'ai dormi tout
le temps et que la télé j'arrive au
foyer plus de télé donc je m'étais mis
un radio réveil et jeu mais je m'étais
skyrock difool et je le laissais tourner
pour avoir du bruit fait une confession
aujourd'hui je ne dors pas sans sans
bruit je ne peux pas été moins quand il
faut dormir je peux pas éteindre la
lumière et dormir j'arrive pas il ya
trop de gamberger à trop de trucs donc
j'éteins la lumière
je mets la radio j'écoute souvent les
grosses têtes relaxe qui assure la
bouffe qu'est ce qu'il ya j'écoutais
grossesse mais quinze minutes je les
entends parler entre eux je les entends
même pas ce n'est même pas ce qu'ils
disent mais au moins il ya quelqu'un qui
parle et je m'endors comme ça et 15
minutes après mon truc qui s'éteint et
je dors je peux pas dormir sans bruit
j'ai pris cette habitude un peu nul mais
ça peut-être ça vient de là